Hello everyone.
Welcome to the Lange focus channel.
In.
My name is Paul.
Today's topic is the languages of Italy.
As you probably know,
Italy is located in Europe on the
Mediterranean Sea and shares borders
with France,
Switzerland,
Austria,
Slovenia in San Marino.
Why not call this video the Italian
language?
That's because Italian,
as we normally think of it,
is not the only language of Italy in
Italy.
There have historically been many
different local varieties of speech that
developed from Vulgar Latin.
These dialects differ significantly from
one locale to another,
but they can be grouped together with
other similar dialects and those groups
have dialects,
can be considered regional languages.
One of these groups have dialects,
is Tuscan for Tulsa,
Donald,
which forms the basis of standard
Italian to be precise.
The Tuscan dialect of Florence spoken in
the 15th,
16th centuries formed the basis of
standard Italian.
The modern Tuscan dialects,
which vary from place to place,
are spoken by around three point $5,
million people,
mainly in Tuscany,
Umbria,
and a couple of locales on the islands
of Sardinia and Corsica.
Standard Italian on the other hand,
is spoken by most of Italy,
60 million people.
It's now learned universally by Italians
because it's the language of education
and the media and in many areas,
especially urban areas,
it has largely replaced the traditional
regional languages in most of the
country,
say from around Rome to the north.
The regional languages are used mostly
amongst the elderly and in more casual
speech,
especially outside of the larger cities
in the south of the country,
specifically in companion,
Calabria and Sicily as well as Sardinia.
Regional languages are more widely
spoken,
but the trend is that the regional
languages are fading for the most part.
Why?
When it's only became a nation in 18,
61,
the policy was to Italian people in all
the different regions of the new
country.
This was done by making Italian the sole
language of education and of media and
of government.
Also internal migration of people
seeking new industrial jobs brought the
speakers of different regional languages
together,
forcing them to speak standard Italian
in order to communicate in such regions.
Notably in the north,
the regional languages have faded more
quickly.
Data from the Italian National Institute
of Statistics shows that around half of
Italians speak mainly Italian with their
families and friends,
and this number rises to 72 point eight
percent when speaking to strangers,
about 33 percent of people speak both
Italian and their dialect with family
and friends,
and 19 percent with strangers.
Sixteen percent speak only their dialect
with their families.
13 point two percent speak only in
dialect with their friends and five
point four percent with strangers.
Notice that I wrote the word dialect
with quotation marks.
We have to be careful with that word
dialect because it might suggest that
these regional languages are varieties
of standard Italian varieties of Tuscan,
but they are not varieties of Italian or
Tuscan from which Italian derived they
developed in parallel with Tuscan their
dialect in the sense that there are many
different local varieties of speech,
but they are not dialects of one single
language.
These dialects are often quite different
from each other and they are grouped
together based on their historical
development.
There are common features and their
mutual intelligibility and can be
thought of as languages,
but most of these languages are not
standardized and exactly how to group
the dialects together is not always
clear and standard Italian spread and
began to replace the traditional
regional languages.
Some features of those traditional
languages made their way into standard
Italian in each area.
This resulted in different dialects of
standard Italian,
mostly different accents and also some
casual vocabulary adopted from those
regional languages.
Some of Italy's language groups are
recognized as historic language
minorities such as Albanian,
German,
Greek,
Slovenian,
Croatian French Frankel,
provont sal for Julian Ladene,
oxytocin,
Katelyn and Sardinian.
Some of these are not romance languages
and some of them are national languages
or regional languages in other nearby
countries.
It's also worth noting that the language
is on this list that are specific to
Italy all have standard written forms
which may be part of the reason they are
recognized as minority languages and not
mere dialects.
Other such languages with standard
written forms are Piedmontese,
the European and Venetian.
The regional language with the largest
number of speakers is neapolitan or
mobility.
It is spoken by around five point 7
million people,
primarily in bustled,
Lazio,
a brute,
so and Malisa Pouliot,
Basilicata and parts of Calabria like
standard Italian and Tuscan.
It is part of the Italo Dalmatian branch
of the romance languages and it has some
degree of intelligibility for speakers
of Italian,
but it's also influenced by Spanish,
French and Arabic.
This is not one of the recognized
minority languages and is often
considered a dialect.
In Italy,
though it's very reasonable to consider
it a separate language.
The second most widely spoken is
Sicilian or Siciliano.
It is spoken by around four point 7
million people,
primarily in Sicily and in parts of
Calabria.
It is also an Italo Dalmatian language
like Neapolitan Sicilian has been
influenced by foreign languages.
Greek,
Arabic,
Spanish,
Katelyn and French.
Sicilian is sometimes said to be the
oldest romance language,
meaning it was the earliest language to
split off from vulgar Latin,
but not everyone accepts this idea.
This is not one of the recognized
minority languages,
either another is Venetian or Veneto,
which is spoken by around three point $9
million people in the Veneto region as
well as a neighboring Trentino Alto,
our Dj and Friuli Veneto Julia.
The nation was a language of prestige
and the time of the Venetian republic
and Venetian was an important part of
the Mediterranean Lingua Franca,
also known as severe,
a regional pigeon language spoken
between the 11th and 19th centuries.
This is also not one of the recognized
minority languages.
Next is Lombard or Lombardo,
which is spoken by three point 6 million
people,
mainly in the lumbar region and parts of
neighboring regions.
It is part of the Gallo Italia Romance
Branch,
along with the Durian and Piedmontese
Piedmontese or pmo and pays is spoken by
around one point 6 million people mainly
in the Piedmont region of northwestern
Italy.
The gear in or Laguna is spoken by
around 500,000
people in the [inaudible] region.
Another Gallo metallic language is
Emilia-romagna.
All this language consists of two
closely related dialect groups,
a million and Roman Yoel.
It is spoken by around one point seven,
3 million people,
mainly in the region of Emilia Romania.
This is not a recognized minority
language.
Next is Sardinian or suicide to do.
It is spoken by around 1 million people,
mainly on the island of Sardinia.
Sardinian is not part of the Italo
Dalmatian branch,
but forms of separate Sardinian branch
of romance languages,
so it's less intelligible for speakers
of Italian.
Then Neapolitan or Sicilian.
Sardinian is a recognized minority
language.
Next is Freudian or foot lung,
which is spoken in the northeastern
region of Friuli by around 600,000
native speakers.
It is a retail romance language that is
related to another language in northeast
Italy.
Ladene as well as the role.
Much language spoken in Switzerland for
Julian is a recognized minority
language.
Ladene is also a recognized minority
language and a spoken by around 50,000
people.
There are also the central Italian
dialects or the [inaudible].
They are spoken in Lazio,
Umbria,
central Medicaid,
the southern part of Tuscany,
and part of a brutal.
These dialects are closely related with
each other and with Tuscan,
and they're all part of the Tallow
Dalmatian branch.
These are thought of as Italian dialects
rather than separate languages,
even though they didn't develop from
Tuscan,
but developed as sister dialects to
Tuscan.
There are around 3 million speakers of
these dialects.
Keep in mind that the number of speakers
for these regional languages might be
misleading because virtually everybody
has also fluent in standard Italian and
their use of the regional languages
might be limited to certain situations.
For example,
in communicating with their elderly
relatives in smaller numbers,
there are also the languages spoken in
neighboring countries either as regional
or national languages.
German through are about 293,000
speakers in northern areas of Italy
adjacent to Germany,
Austria and Switzerland.
Franco provolone solve has around 90,000
speakers in the north near France,
mostly in Piedmont.
Albanian has around 80,000
speakers.
Slovene has around 70,000
speakers near the border with Slovenia.
Oxytocin has around 40,000
speakers in Piedmont and the Judea.
Katelyn is spoken by around 20,000
people in the city of alligator on
Sardinia,
which began as a Katelyn settlement.
Keeping in mind that the regional
romance languages are generally
considered dialects in Italy.
I thought it would be fun to have a look
at some of them at see how similar or
different they are.
Let's look at standard Italian
Neapolitan Sardinian and for Uli in it,
allegedly,
this means I would like something to
read word for word.
It's would like first person singular,
something to read and to Neapolitan
whooley causality.
Judah here,
the words all correspond and if you're
looking for it,
you can see the connection between the
words,
but the words are also different enough
to make comprehensive difficult
neapolitan words are often shorter than
the Italian equivalence with final
vowels or final syllables reduced.
In Italian,
there's vote a.
This becomes valueless in Neapolitan.
I've also seen this spelled with an e at
the end.
Neapolitan spelling is not standardized.
Italian quality causa is Qaqc course in
Neapolitan.
The Italian preposition dot meaning from
or buy,
but also used to be for an infinitive
like this becomes our in the Apollo.
Isn't the word for reed is similar
except the final vowel sound after our
is more like the Schwab in the Apollo
written more like an ah sound.
Unstressed.
Vowels often sounds like Schwab in the
Apollo isn't and these reduced vowels
are sometimes not written in Sardinian.
You have all the lead,
unlike an Italian Neapolitan in which
the Personal Pronoun Ego was dropped
here,
it's included and didn't Sardinian it's
Ia,
but I believe this can also be dropped
in.
Sardinian boldly is the conditional form
of the verb which comes from the same
root as the Italian Neapolitan once,
but it takes on a different form and
Sardinian here.
Quality Coza is represented by two
words,
I believe means some on its own.
Here at the preposition is slightly
different and then we have the verb
meaning to read,
which is obviously related to the
others,
but the infinitive is formed differently
and in Freeland evil that is here we see
the personal pronoun.
He in Freeland,
this can't be dropped.
The verb here clearly comes from the
same root as the others,
but this one takes on quite a different
form and as a learner of Italian,
I might mistake this for the Italian
word velocity,
which means to fly.
The word for something is out.
I don't actually know the root of this
word,
but the way I'll remember it is that it
sounds like the middle of quality.
Cool.
Now I'll never forget this word here.
Notice the slightly different
preposition and notice the infinitive of
the verb,
meaning to read.
This looks quite different from the
Italian word,
but it looks rather similar to the
French word Leah or Spanish layer.
So far.
You can probably notice a lot of
similarity when you look at the
sentences,
but there's also enough difference to
make these mutually unintelligible to a
large extent.
When they're spoken Miano date that is
solely owned Digi.
This sentence means they told me that we
will arrive around 11:00
word for word.
It's to me,
they have said that we will arrive
around the 11 in the Apollo written
modernity took here we see that the
object pronoun contracts with the verb
and notice again that a neapolitan,
the final vowel becomes reduced to a
Schwa sound.
The main verb here that he is the
equivalent of Ditto in Italian,
d sounds in Italian,
often correspond to our sounds in
Neapolitan.
The Word K is pronounced cook when
unstressed and contracts with the
following verb because of its initial
vowel sound,
the Italian word or got a mall is a vm
in Neapolitan pay is the equivalent of
pad in Italian,
meaning for the wounded she becomes
liquid in the show.
Once again,
notice all those reduced sounds in
Sardinian monthly.
Now do by region.
Here we can see that similar to the
other languages in Sardinia in the past
can be expressed by using the auxiliary
verb,
meaning to have,
even though it looks quite different,
the unsound is a hint.
The main verb,
however,
is different.
I'll speculate that this for now is
related to the Latin verb.
Not meaning to tell or narrate,
though I'm not sure.
Okay.
In Italian is cut the future tenses from
differently and Sardinian with an
auxiliary verb.
Here,
instead of [inaudible],
we see a candidate which is similar to
the Italian preposition,
a controller,
which means beside here we have a
different definite article and wounded.
She becomes wound Digi inferiorly and
inferiorly and it seems that rather than
use a specific indirect object,
pronouns to preposition is used with the
object pronouns like to me here on dee
dee is the past tense,
formed the same way as an Italian
Neapolitan,
but with different forms.
Here we have the subject pronouns which
is not necessary and the other
languages,
and here we have the verb for arrive,
but you might not have immediately
recognized it because it begins with a
single are rather than an a and a double
are told is the preposition meaning
around and dish is own.
She will do it for a trestle.
This sentence means I have two brothers
and three sisters,
word for word.
It's have first person,
singular present tense,
two brothers and three sisters in
Neapolitan.
Doing good grief.
Raga in the Italian sentence,
notice that the verb for how is a form
of the verb of ETA,
but in the Neapolitan sentence,
it's taking the.
This is similar to the word used in
Spanish.
In Italian there's a word like this,
tenacity,
which would be 10 goal in the first
person singular,
but that means to hold in your hand,
not to have in the general sense here.
The word for to is slightly different.
Here.
The word for brothers is flat rather
than fill out daily,
and the word for sisters is also
shortened Soda Rather Than Soda.
And notice that the production of the
endings make the gender of nouns
somewhat unclear.
In this case,
of course,
we know because of their meaning,
but with other nouns,
the gender might be less clear in
Sardinian.
Here's the verb tense is similar to the
Neapolitan.
One Tango to is deuce rather than do it,
and three is today's rather than three.
Both the verb and the numbers remind me
of Spanish here next.
Friday's and Saudis mean brother and
sister respectively,
and notice that they formed the plural
by adding an s.
This is how it's done in many romance
languages,
but not in standard Italian in which the
final vowel of the word indicates number
in for Julian.
Again,
we see that the Pronoun can't be dropped
in for your lead.
Here we see the verb to have,
which is a cognate with the verb and the
Italian sentence.
Unlike the ones in the Neapolitan and
Sardinian sentences,
it's pronounced it,
but you can see a connection with the
French word a to his dose,
like in Spanish.
The word for brother is basically the
same as the Sardinian word,
and the plural is formed by adding s.
The word for sister Sol is like the
French word,
so as you can see from these examples,
there's a lot of linguistic diversity in
Italy with regional languages and their
local dialects having their own colorful
features that reflect the history and
the traditions of their speakers.
Many of these languages and dialects are
endangered and risk being completely
replaced by standard Italian.
In the coming generations.
There are some efforts to preserve these
languages,
but will they succeed?
And that brings me to the question of
the day for people who speak both
Italian and another language of Italy,
how often do you use your traditional
local language and in what situations
and for learners of Italian has the
influence of these traditional languages
and dialects ever affected your
communication with native speakers?
Let us know in the comments down below.
Be sure to follow lane,
focus on facebook,
twitter,
and instagram.
And once again,
thank you to all of my wonderful patrion
supporters,
especially these ones right here on the
screen for their monthly pledges.
Thank you for watching and have a nice
day.